I only respond when there's an emergency
there you go okay thanks everybody I'm
just kidding
on October 4th hundreds of millions of
cell phones across the U.S received a
text message and that alert tone as part
of a test of the national emergency
alert system so many of us grew up with
the emergency broadcast system right
this is a test this station is
conducting a test at the emergency
broadcasting system
this is only a test getting that tone on
your TV that interrupted whatever
program you were watching this is just
the modern version of that going to
people's cell phones Nationwide alerts
for mobile devices were in the works
since the September 11 2001 terrorist
attacks but didn't become operational
until 2012. Federal Law requires the
government to conduct a nationwide test
at least every three years the purpose
of the test is to ensure that the
emergency response systems continue to
be effective means of warning the public
about emergencies this is the third time
FEMA has conducted a wireless Nationwide
test of all cell phone emergency alerts
but a second test to all cellular
devices getting alerts out promptly to
our communities saves lives that's why
FEMA is working with the Federal
Communications Commission and your local
public safety authorities on this test
there are four different types of
wireless emergency alerts National or
presidential alerts which can only be
issued by the president during a
National Emergency imminent threat
alerts involving hazards on the local
level like extreme weather Amber Alerts
about missing or abducted children and
Public Safety alerts which have
information about threats that may not
be as imminent more than sixteen hundred
federal state and local authorities use
what's known as the integrated public
alert and warning system or ipaws to
issue alerts and warnings to people in
their jurisdictions most cell phones
powered on Within Reach of a cell phone
tower and participating in wireless
service should be triggered by the
national test television shows and radio
broadcasts will also be interrupted with
an emergency test message only local
emergency alerts like Amber Alerts or
severe weather warnings can be disabled
in advance you cannot opt out of a
national alert and that's because it is
sent by the president so if the
president is deciding to send an alert
it's considered important enough that
you should receive it no matter what
aside from test alerts the president has
not to my knowledge ever sent a national
alert while the national alert system
has only been tested authorities have
used this system locally more than 84
000 times since 2012. making it a
challenge for authorities to decide how
often to hit send you know they're
constantly trying to find that balance
of what's too much and what's too little
if you don't send enough alerts then
then you might not be reaching everyone
versus if you send too many
you might desensitize people there's
very much that balance or that needle
that they're trying to thread for FEMA
the Nationwide test is a chance to make
sure the Federal Government Can alert
the entire country in the event of a
nationwide emergency we want to make
sure that when it counts we can keep you
informed the next alert you receive
could save your life or the life of ones
you love
thank you